go hey hey everyone it's Michael BOS
here and this is the overflows market
analysis for May 9 2017 Now Stocks held
steady is kind of a narrow trading range
uh that was down about 2% oil is down
about 50 cents testing support around 46
bucks tomorrow you got the inventory
numbers dollar is still benefiting from
post French election selling in the Euro
but uh you know honestly it was kind of
a crappy day for trading um you know
there was there was a few really
standout moments in the markets uh which
I'll get to in a moment but you know
markets like the interest rates the 5
years was uh you I say difficult but you
there just wasn't anything there same
with uh snps you know it had been a very
tight range most of the morning in snps
that it was just it was just really
sitting around you know doing nothing
and you know one of the things you know
people come to me with order flows is
they think oh orderflow is going to give
me every single turn in the market no
it's it's not it's going to give you
those moments when something's happening
and you know the way I the way I um you
know good analogy for orderflow is like
soccer you know in America you know we
call it soccer in Europe the rest of the
world it's called football right and not
to be confused with football Americano
but um you know when you watch soccer
you know to most Americans soccer is
extremely boring and honestly you it
wasn't until I moved to Singapore that I
really found you know soccer to be you
know really understood soccer soccer in
Singapore you know English Premier
League is huge out there and yeah it's
literally just sitting around yeah
yawning you know passing the ball I mean
you know I remember when the World Cup
was in Chicago you know and teams were
playing for a draw you know just passing
the ball around and you know I mean
Americans just didn't get it um you know
we want a winner and but you know
there's those moments in the soccer
match where you know you get the moment
of Brilliance you know where the guy
gets the ball controls the ball and
dribbles past you know two or three
Defenders and puts the ball in the back
of the net and that's what orderflows is
like it's those moments of Brilliance
you know that just really stand out in
the market it said it's not going to
give you every high and every low don't
don't think it is but it's going to give
you you know those moments where you
know the market is telling you something
and saying hey you know get short here
you should you know be getting long here
and is it right 100% of the times no
it's not you know I I don't want people
coming in to overflow thinking oh this
is going to you know make my computer
money out next week it it's not
like that you know it's it takes time to
learn but it doesn't take a lot of time
you know it's it's something that can be
learned relatively quick and you could
use it in your trading you know within a
few days yeah I don't want to say the
next day but you know realistically U
you know give it a couple days to get
used to it and familiar with watching
the markets but uh so let's just jump
into it you know brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or or make any
other type of investment decision future
training contain substantial risk is not
for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all and more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without shepardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results some of the indicators I'll be
talking about in this presentation is
the order fls Traders my footprint chart
the Delta scalper and the price rejector
um you know these the last two are some
of my proprietary indicators and let's
uh jump into it we'll start with the 5
years now five years was interesting
again you know what I was talking about
earlier where it just felt the market
was going nowhere um you know this
morning we got this one bar here right
in the low of the day in the 5 years at
the time it was the low and you're
putting in massive volume now this bar
itself traded 73 77,000 contracts and at
this level here of
29 you know you got 21,000 trade on the
bid 14,000 on the offer so you know
you're looking at 35,000 there another
um you know 15,000 on the bid here 7,000
on the offer so you know you're looking
you know in this area you're looking
about 50,000 Lots going through more or
less right around you know 29 28 3/4 and
I thought you know okay maybe this is
going to be my support or resistance you
know depending on how it goes then the
next bar you know we open up we start
trading lower I'm thinking hey this is
going to be my resistance what happens
you trade right back up you get up into
this area up here very low volume I mean
this is at the end of the day so it
filled in a little bit more but I was
really looking as this as
being um you know if we could stay if we
keep the points of controls below this
level you know even though price is
trading above really what you got to be
watching is the point of control in the
bar I mean price can rotate higher it
could rotate lower but you got to be
keeping the point of control lower for
the market to be heading lower if the
point of control starts popping up above
this 29 area you know then forget about
thinking of it as
resistance and why do I think just
because I see a big number here Mike
says it's resistance
well at this time you know if we're
going to stay below it you know a lot of
selling here right and there's buyers
okay but if these buyers are are done
buying what's going to happen to the
market who's left to buy you know
eventually later on there was more
buying but you know if they're not there
to hold this market up the Market's
going to go lower right and conversely
you know if the sellers that are selling
into these bids here the you know 35,000
Lots here if these sellers get tired and
you
know can't got no more inventory to sell
what's the market going to do it's going
to start gradually going up and anyway
in this case you know this is why
usually it's very clear you know today
this
morning I'll say it wasn't clear but it
just wasn't clear um you know we we got
through that level started trading lower
then we start putting in some massive
numbers even below it you know you know
down here at 28 28 and 3/4 you can see
it down here but again you know the
important thing is we're keeping below
the point of controls are keeping below
this 29
level and you know it's not until much
later after the cash market closes that
you do rally back up through here but
again you know it
it you the thing that doesn't make this
look nice you know even though the point
of controls are below is that you this
one bar poked up through it although you
do get a ratio a bearish ratio which
coincides at the same level with with
this um bearish ratio this one's a ratio
bounds high this is a ratio bounds low
ratio bounds low indicates stopping
volume ratio bounds High indicates you
know price
rejection you know earlier you had price
rejection now you got price defense here
and but point of control is still below
we do tick a little bit lower um you
know not like moving 10 points lower
anything like that still you know from
28 and A2 down to you know 26 and2 the
decent move but you know then on this
low what do you got you got
a finally you got a reason to buy you've
got a Divergence you got a ratio bounds
low indicating some stopping volume
there and you got the buying in balances
coming in here and we start to Rally up
off this low you know this was a little
bit clearer but you know again it's a
bit later um honestly I would have liked
this to be a little bit clearer what I
would have liked is not and gotten back
up to 29 and 1/2 you know maybe trade up
29 29 and A4 29 and half is a little bit
pushing it for me but again it's I I
hate that term it is what it is but it
is what it is you know I it's it's got
to be the most um one of the few phrases
I I just don't like but um you know
that's what happened in the market you
can only trade what the market gives you
now the
bonds the Bond's very similar actually
um know let's take a look here at the
bonds in the
morning
and so let's expand that a bit so we're
coming in here you know this 24 area you
know it was an area you you putting in
your point of control for the day at
that time um getting a lot some decent
volume in here and we just couldn't go
anywhere we got three point controls
lined up actually you got four even if
you go back to this previous bar but
here 1 two 3 you got alternating candles
you got green uh red green red green red
dogey um um and you got very small
Deltas here for the most part you got
you know 200 128 358 140
3218 um you know you do get the big
negative and you follow with the big
positive you do have a Divergence a
couple times here um here and here it
doesn't rally it's not a ratio that I
like it's just you know a normal
orderflow ratio so again you don't be
thinking oh I got every um you know I
got to pick every bottom or every turn
in the market no um you know sometimes
it's it's obvious sometimes it's not
obvious you know it's not until you get
later down here that you have a ratio
you like 0.5 and the Divergence and you
see how the market rallied up and now
people ask well what's the ratio well
you just it reads the order flow in the
bar is what it does just makes the
analysis a bit easier um for me you know
if if it's a blue number it's a number I
like if it's a black number it's just
the the regular
orderflow um you know volume that's
going through in the bar um but you know
for me when it stands out when it's a
number I
like then you know it's actionable does
it mean every sing
one is actionable no you know I like him
on on swing highs swing lows lows of the
day highs of the day and you know
certain areas but um so you can see you
know this one did you know if you're
just trying to buy every Divergence
you're going to get whacked you know
this one failed this one failed wasn't
until you get down here the ratio with
the Divergence that the market reacted
and
rallied and you know but still it was it
was kind of a quiet day now the other
interesting thing is you got these point
of controls all lined up here this is
going to be your either support or
resistance level depending on what
happens in the next bar again if point
of control is below look for the market
to come off a little bit you know
basically you have a market generated
level
automatically um you know you could use
you use whatever indicator you like okay
is it Market generated information
people argue oh yeah it takes the price
of the market well yeah well yeah you
could take price and manipulate any way
you want to give you know the desired
effect whereas you know if you're
looking at orderflow this is the reality
of the market market and you know it's
telling you here at this level of um you
know 26 that you know people are happy
to transact and if you're just look at a
normal bar chart you don't see this
information now you know if everyone's
happy to trade at these levels then you
know what what's the market going to do
is it going to become a support level is
it going to become a resistance level in
this case became resistance level you
got the you finally got out of this area
of trading sideways you got this bar
what does the bar trade right up to it
trades right up to resistance level and
point of control lower so that's
negative you know we do get a little bit
of a move lower um unfortunately it
wasn't much of a move I said it was kind
of a blah day in the markets in the
interest rates
yesterday but it comes down to this
level where you get a bar a bullish
signal here you got the Divergence and
you have the ratio again you I said you
know if you just have ratios by
themselves I don't think that's just
good enough you know you want to see
something in the order flow to um excite
you and you know the ratio EX you just
like you saw in the 5 years you hit the
low with the Divergence and a ratio the
market rallied here in the bonds you hit
the low with the Divergence and a ratio
and the market rallied you know if you
get overflow software you know mine is
you know I don't say I'm the creator of
this you know but I'm the one that well
actually I am I I'll take credit for it
I know other people are copying it and
putting it out there as some algo
orderflow algo or
orderflow Price blah blah blah um you
it's it's not it's just a simple just
reads the order flow in the bar and if
it's bullish you know you could even
adjust it so if you want a different
type of number you know say you want to
set it at 25 which would make this one a
bullish one um you can you know I have
my parameters that I use to you know
tell me you know based on my many years
of experience of trading that you know
what numbers I like to look for again
you know not every time you have a
Divergence and a ratio the Market's
going to Rally or sell off but you know
it's a high percentage of the time
so you know those markets interest rates
were kind
of uh say difficult but
um you just a kind of a stagnant Market
this morning is really what it felt like
it just you know felt like a market that
was struggling to make any type of move
now the
eurocurrency again you know going back
to you know
orderflow sometimes you know things are
just so Crystal
Clear and you know let's just go back to
what I'm referring
to this morning around
7 um you know 7:45 7:46 this morning
coming into this
low and again you know this is to me
this is you know a beautiful you know
textbook is said if you could take a
take a picture of this post it up on the
wall just look for this this everyday
you know that you then go for it but uh
what it is Euro currency coming into the
lows boom you hit this low look at this
volume down here at the low point of
control on the bars a green candle so
you know it was selling earlier and it
rallied you got negative Delta but you
got Point control at the bottom you got
a ratio of bullish ratio you know if it
was a bearish ratio it would appear on
the top but it's a green bar so it
appears underneath on a red bar it
appears on top and it's telling you
there's very good stopping volume down
here and you know doesn't mean it's
enough to turn this into a level that
you could watch for weeks no but it
turns it into a level for the short term
for now you know again I'm not you're
trading with order flow you're not
trading longterm you're just trying to
pick up you know ticks during the day
you're not looking for you know picking
a level that's going to hold for a month
or anything like
that but in this case you know it this
is this is very obvious you know point
of control right at the bottom is
important you've got a ratio that's
important and you start to Rally even in
the next bar you still got a bullish
ratio and you got this imbalance down
here which is this green Arrow so even
if you're not convinced that hey you
know what this Market's going to turn
here you're getting the signal in the
next bar that the Market's going to be
turning here and we make a nice move up
we make a nice move from you know
10898 all the way up to you know before
it were starts coming dip down a little
bit up to the uh you know the 12 13 14
area you know that's a decent move in
the currencies euro currency now a
little bit later you this is a sell this
is a Delta scop we're giving you a sell
but it's a green it's a sell on a green
bar you know why why why in hell would
you want to take it you shouldn't but
what you want to be taken is the sell on
the Red Bar you know here fortunately
this Market just goes sideways and then
gives you a buy Here Delta scalper gives
you a buy this is also the transition
this yellow one I don't know if you can
see that I don't really talk about those
indicators much but still that's a buy
Delta surge in the next bar but really
this the key is in this bar here um the
signals with the Delta scalper green bar
you know just says the Delta scoper was
here unfortunately this Market just went
sideways on you it didn't really put a
move lower um but now it's reversing
it's giving you a buy and then you get a
nice little move up here before it turns
around comes back down but again you
know it's a decent move over the next uh
two or three bars you know from the six
17 1617 area up to the 27 area um
nothing at this turn up
here again you know you go lower you got
the Delta surge right down here you here
you got the Delta scalper given a buy
but again it's a red bar so I probably
not be too interested in taking it even
though the market did dip down before
putting in a nice rally higher again
that's something that you'd have to
decide do you want to take or
not this is this red I sorry red this
yellow arrow is the volatil transition
which is basically telling you the
market had been in a demand driven
market now I think it's shifting into a
supply driven Market where Supply is
coming into market and you can see
there's there's a bit of selling you
know in all in these Deltas 20 6 120 64
245 101 the market does you know it
takes a while takes about 5 minutes
before it comes off from this uh 15 area
down to the uh 109 area bounces up a
little bit and gives Delta scalper by
yeah just goes sideways before it
probably stops you out and then just
goes down into the new lows but really
the most stand itish thing the most
obvious thing you know that's what you
got to be looking for is the most
obvious stuff you know stuff that just
screams out at you and this just screams
out at you this bar right here says Hey
buy
me and you're rewarded for it just said
you don't have to try and you oh you
know we hit an overbought level I think
I should sell here or oh we hit the
upper band of this um trading band you
know maybe I should sell you know this
is so obvious um I said if if you use
order flow for nothing else then point
of controls then you know you you'll be
so far ahead of traders
that you know I mean I I could stand up
on this on the top of this well it's not
Sears Tower but the Willows tower now
and scream you know use orderflow you
know people will people won't um you
know sometimes it again like it's like
you could lead a horse to water but
getting it to drink is another story but
you know sometimes know things are just
so obvious like like this that you know
it's going to give you a nice
trade okay now the other Market that was
you know set up kind of nicely was the
soybeans again I I like soybeans you
know it goes back to my Cargill trading
days um I I do think grains do give
people very good opportunities in the
market soybeans uh soybeans we corn is
is a bit of a boore to trade honestly
especially uh you know when it's in one
of its uh 3 Cent trading range modes and
you know that that's going to be a bit
boring but you know soybeans gives you
good movements wheat gives you good
movement honestly you know I mean you
can make a good living just trading
soybeans or trading
wheat you know on an intraday basis now
8:30 is when the market reopens from you
know the trading halt from the overnight
session and you know so 8:30 833 we hit
this High Red Bar ratio point of control
at the top very similar only it's it's a
sell versus you know in the euro
currency you had it as a buy and you
know honestly I do like it I I remember
talking about in the room I thought hey
we could start to sell off we do sell
off in the next bar but it comes right
back up hits level okay this one didn't
work out you sometimes they work out
very beautifully but this one's you know
I'm not going to try and say oh I
wouldn't take it because it's close to
the open but you know again you know you
do have opening um 8:30 you do have you
know what's considered the opening range
you know usually it's the first minute
but you know the way these alos work you
know Cash open you know it does take
them about 5 minutes more or less to
sort of work out you know their their
different waves and sub waves of
execution you know they're not just
going to someone enters an algo to buy
you know 500 soybean contracts it's not
going to do it as fast as it can it's
going to it's going to finesse it and
you know take as much time but anyway
that said this one didn't work out okay
again I don't want to say well Mike said
you know every time you get up here you
got to sell it it's it's a go-to trade
that every time it works this one didn't
work out I'll be honest you know it came
right back up and you can see up up here
at 972 you got resistance you got some
volume 508 did get through there on a
nice uh buying and buying IM balance did
go higher now we start coming off start
coming
off you hit your high negative Delta all
up in here look at all these bars
negative Deltas now this is where I I
found it very interesting this to me
this
was I was talking about this in the room
I was very excited about this we start
coming off you hit the swing low here at
970 you got 240 traded you know you got
15 you got unfinished business here we
came back un finished business we closed
okay fair enough I'll give you that 240
trade 19 trade but watch this Delta it's
getting you know minus it's coming off
this high but the Delta is waning you
know- 399 - 138 - 83 minus 51 and Bam
very strong positive Delta 474 buying
coming in and even got the Delta scalper
given a buy and what does it do starts
working its way up from the 971 and a
half
area rally up you know get within a tick
of the high and come off a little bit
boom make a new high still still hanging
up above this 971 and A2 area no reason
to be getting out little later on starts
coming back in aggressive buying coming
in you know 500 122 makes new
highs makes new highs going you know all
the way up until uh
1240 again this market closes at
basically 1115 so you know realistically
he should be looking to get out you know
around 12 12:30 I'm not going to say
hold it all the way going into the close
um but you know it was it was a decent
move you know that one was this was a
bit obvious I think you know again I
it's obvious if you were in the room you
heard me talk about it this one again
you know I like this I I did think this
was bearish it just didn't work out but
again you know you could be you're only
talking about you know getting short
here at the
971 with a stop just above this high at
972 and a quarter so it's not like
you're risking a lot you're risking a
penny more or less or you know a penny
and a cent so you're risking five ticks
at maximum
maximum um but you know you're getting
it back in here from
971 971 and a quarter all the way up to
976 now the last
uh thing I'll talk about really quick
is the uh what is
it the transition indicator um you saw
me talk about a little bit on on a
couple of the other charts but let me
just find the chart I got really running
on is is this this is the me uh me my
uh Dow chart I like it on I I like you
know for very short-term trades you know
quick in and out if you're a short-term
Trader you want to trade in day I do
think you could use a dow uh it's great
contract five bucks a tick I'm not
telling everyone go out and start
trading down don't get me wrong you know
don't say go the NFA will come down on
me or whatever but getting some nice
moves here you know buy here the sell
you wouldn't be interested in taking
which the reason is even though you have
a sell signal let the next bar Lead You
In you know get
confirmation this decent sell here yeah
a little bit of sell here before it
comes back a little rally nice little
rally here before it goes sideways again
it's not an indicator when you're using
a 100 tick chart don't be thinking
you're buying it here and you're going
to be holding it for an hour it's a
you're trading a 100 tick chart you
you're should be in and out in and out
relatively uh you know adeptly as soon
as signs of signs the Market's not
working in your favor get out you know
here's a nice sell and here's a nice buy
here's a buy maybe you know you take it
because it did start poking up and then
it stops you out really quick at a small
loss then you know going into the close
boom you get a nice sell here and
obviously again I'm not saying you you'd
sell it at at you know right ahead of
cash close and hold it into the evening
session but you know this was a nice
little sell going you know for the last
hour of the
day
so you know thanks for watching this and
to learn more about trading software and
how to trade with orderflow visit my
website www. order flows.com and thank
you for your time and listening to me
bye-bye